this time of year there's no sight more
welcome than a nice warm Pub but that
warmth is fast becoming a liability
for Hospitality venues like this one
energy costs for heating and cooking
make it harder and harder to balance the
books scandalous isn't it is
it's a joke
we cannot operate in darkness we need
electricity for everything we do
but the price of it has gone up
six thousand pounds per month that's not
per annum that's per month you cannot
pass that level of increase back onto a
consumer and such as what's that on your
bottom line
up until April gas and electricity unit
costs have been camped much as they are
for households but the chancellor has
now unveiled a new last generous scheme
no government can continue to subsidize
indefinitely higher energy prices but
what we can do which matters to all
those businesses is to bring down
inflation and that means we have to be
responsible with public finances but at
the same time today we're announcing
five and a half billion pounds that's
nearly a penny on income tax for every
taxpayer in the country to help
businesses through this difficult period
what difference this all makes depends
on something even the treasury can't
control wholesale gas and electricity
prices right now they're capped at
around this level as you can see current
prices are actually below the cap the
new scheme will lift that threshold and
only give businesses a discount once
prices rise above it meaning they're
much more exposed if those lines leap
again the fact that it's the treasury
rather than the business department down
the road there making this announcement
it's actually quite significant that
place is all about growth it's about
supporting businesses whereas this place
well it's more about tightening the
purse strings and there's no doubting
this is going to be a lot cheaper than
what came before it the question is what
damage is left in its wake
businesses have already warned this will
lead to layoffs and closures
the government says it can't support
them forever in practice that means
companies large and small facing a
further squeeze this coming year at
Conway Sky News